[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكيد الجيش
الروسيه انه بدا سحب قوته من خرسون
الاوكرانيه بعد يوم من اعلنه الانسحاب من
الضفه اليمين لنهر دين برو وحيث تقع عاصمه
المنطقه وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
وحدات لجنود الروس تجري منورات باتجاههم
موقع معدن لها على ضفه اليسار من نهري
دنبرو بما يتوافق بشكل صارم مع الخطط
المقرره هذا فيما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
استعادته لسنه عشره بلده في منطقه الخرصون
بمساحه تزيد عن 260 كيلو متر مربعا كيف
تلقت بحذر اعلان الانسحاب روسين مشيرتنا
الى انها تشتبع في ان موسكوت اريد جره
قوتها الى معركه مدن صعبه
رئيس الاوكرانيا حضره من النوايا الروسيه
قائلا لا نعرف نواياهم هل سيخوضون قتالا
معنا وي بيقولوا لنا التمسك بمدينه خرسون
انهم يتحركون ببطء شديد
[موسيقى]
هنا فش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي المختصه في
الشؤون السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الروسيه
المعهد الوطني الاوكراني للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من اكياس السعيده بخروج القوات
الروسيه من خيرسون هل من حق كياف سيد
الكسندر ان تفرح او كما يقول الغرب وبعد
حتى تصريحات الاوكرانيه يجب ان نبقى
حاذرين لانه يمكن ان يكون هذا تراجع هو
تراجع تكتيكي ليس اكثر
لا اعتقد ان هو تكشيكه لان هناك اكثر من
مؤشر انه فعلا القوات الروسيه يعني نوويه
الي الانسحاب لكن هل الانسحاب لا يتم
بطريقه الحربي يعني مثل هروب يعني مثل ما
حدث سابقا يعني على استعداد وكان مستعدين
يعني
خلال الفتره معينه يعني من الوقت
مؤشرات من ضمن المؤشرات يعني عمليات صرب
النائب منهجه
وتدميرا المباني
هي مؤشرات التي تؤشر ان القوات الروسيه
غير البقعه لمده
عن اهميه خرسان حتى انا البعض اسمها هذه
المعركه همم المعركه الام همم هكذا يسميها
او يصفها البعض ولكن هل تعتقدين انه همم
القوات الروسيه خرجت من خرسون كما يقول
ضيفي لانها لم ترد البقاء لاسباب ليس
التكتيكيه كما يرجحه واذا لماذا
مساء الخير نعم همم اذا كان هناك فرح
بعاصمه اوكرانيا
فباروسيا هناك شعور حزن واكثر من ذلك
الصدمه همم لانه هذا الانسحاب هو مقلق
للغايه ونزعج الالهايه للغايه من يقارن
هذا الشيء باحداث في تاريخ روسيا القيصريه
وهذا ادى فيما بعد الى اضطرابات داخليه في
داخل روسيا
هناك قلقه همم وحذر شديد ولكن انا من
مصادر اعرف انه نحن مازلنا الان في تقاطع
الطرق هناك توجهه يقول بان روسيا على كل
ان ما زالت تتحضر للهجوم المضاده ولكن متى
سيحدث قبل نهايه هذه السنه
وفي الربيع القادم هذا حتى الان همم غير
واضح وعلى كلن عشان ينجح همم او عشان تنجح
هذه الخطه نحن سنكون بحاجه لموجات جديده
من التعبئه العامه لاي درجه الراي العامه
روسيا تراجعت لانها تتحضر ل همم نوعيه
اخرى من التقدم جوا هذه المره هي تستعد
للقصف الى اي مداه هذا يمكن ان يكون دقيق
بالنسبه للقصف لا يوجد شيء مضحك لانه
روسيا الان تراهن على تدمير البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه والقصف كان مستمر حتى
بعد محاوله تفجير جسر
في اوكرانيا وهو مختص اصلا في هذه
المواضيع في صواريخ وقنابل وقوات جويه همم
القصب هذا بحاد ذاته لن يؤدي الى تقدم على
الارض انا اتحدث انه هل هناك سيكون تقدم
على الارض في مناطق اخرى مثلا روسيا اليوم
حتى اخذت همم مدينه صغيره او قريه كبيره
مثل ما نسميها
فضلتك في همم شرق اوكرانيا وهذا بعد
المعارك شرسه ولكن الراي العام في روسيا
يريد ان يكون هناك تقدم اكثر في مناطق عده
هل تستطيع ان تحقق هذا الشيء اذا ما
استطعت فحسب علمه هناك جهود متوازيه وهي
جهود تف هي عن طريق تركيا عن طريق دول
عربيه
لهذا الجانب لانه جانب كذلك يستحق النقاش
هل من مفاوضات ممكنه في هذا توقيت ولكن
دكتور الكسندر ما تعليقك على كلام ضيف
سيارته تقول بانه همم صحيح هناك تراجع
ولكن روسيا تدرس خطواتها ويجب على كيف ان
تحذر
عن العلم انه روسيا فقدت قوه بشريه هائله
يعني في هذه المعارك يعني وبالذات يعني في
معركه
فهناك ما تبقى من الجيش النظامي الروسي
المتدرب
قليل يعني جدا يعني ينفع بالنسبه للتعبئه
بطريقه صعبه جدا يعني فهو الناس غير
متدربين الذين يزجون بيهم بالمعارك يعني
يستعملهم همم الروسي يعني علف المضافه
ضحايا في صفوف هؤلاء الناس هناك نسبه
كبيره من الاستسلام
[موسيقى]
القوه الاردنيه
الراجل العام المجتمع الروسي كان
معانا مزعوج بسبب هذه التعبئه فموجات
جديده من التعبئه ممكن ان تشكل ضغطا
اجتماعيا
الذي طرحها ضيفه ويقول عمليه التعبئه
بطريقه عشوائيه هم غير متدربين يرمى بهم
الى الحروب بطريقه غير مدروسه
انه كانت هناك اخطاء في مجال التعبئه انا
اعترض فيها الاخطاء كانت ولكن الان وزير
الدفاع الروسيه اتخذ شخصيا اتخذ اجراءات
مهمه للتصحيح هذه الاخطاء وانا متاكده انه
موجود التاليه
للتعبئه اذا تطلب الامر حتكون انجح بكثير
اكمل فكرتك دكتور الكسندر كنت تحدثني عن
الحظر الذي ربما يحرك اوكرانيا كذلك من
جهتها
الخبر على انه فعلا يعني وجود الروسي يعني
ما زال موجود يعني هناك قوات المسلات يعني
وما تبقى من النخبه الروسيه المزلات يعني
القوات المسلحه بالذات موجود يعني في
مدينه خيرسون الى حد الان هما الاستعداد
للتصدي يعني هذا الشيء بارد صحيح اما اااا
بصراحه لو لو بقوا يعني لو ما ينصحبوا
هؤلاء القوات فستقي روسيا بدون قوات
النخبه
بالخالص يعني تقريبا
عشان ارواح هؤلاء الناس يعني يفهمهما يعني
همم تاخذ القرار المساحات قدام الرئيسيه
يعني اما بالنسبه بالنسبه للخاله العامه
الاستراتيجيه فروسه لا تقدر نحن انقطاعنا
عليهم كل الطرق الليدات فهؤلاء الناس هناك
يعني ستره طويله بدون انذار بدون ذخيره
بدون اكل يعني حتى خيانه يعني فصعب عليهم
البقايا يعني فسيتم سيتم الاستقامه على اي
حاله لان لكن بطريقه تدريجيه وليست بطريقه
مثل ما كانت عليه سابقا في القرصهم حيث
جاء الجيش الروسي وهرب يعني بسرعه هائله
جدا تاركين حتى المعدات والدبابات همم
اكوام يعني همم يعني همم عاليه جدا يعني
من المعدات العسكريه المدافع العراق هناك
همم يعني همم
هناك همم محاوله يعني من قبل القياده
الروسيه لكن همم
انسحاب بطريقه غير عشوائيه بطريقه مرتبه
لكن هذا عامر صعب عليهم جدا لانه ما في
هناك الطرق طرق للانسحاب لان الطرق
الاسترخاء كذلك الصعبه الجسور مدمره ال-
همم الزوارق هي اهداف بسيطه جدا يعني
للمدفعيه الاوكرانيه فالجيش الاوكراني
قريب جدا من هؤلاء الناس يعني من طرق
الانسحاب ذلك يعني
همم ما تفضل به ضيفي بان روسيا ليست لديها
القدره حتى على التراجع يعني حتى همم عوده
قواعدها لم تدرسوا انت مش موافقه طيب همم
خلينا نحكي في النقطه لانه كان سؤال
يتمحور حول عدم القدره الروسيه لا على
التقدم ولا حتى على العوده طيب ما الذي
تفعله اذا يقرا يعني من يتحمل المسؤوليه
همم اطاله اما الحرب
لا هون ضيفكم من اوكرانيا يبالغ هذا واضح
انه لديهم فرح وهذا ايضا جزء من الحرب
النفسيه ولكن هم فقدوا 16% من اراضيهم وين
نتحدث على عن اي شيء
اوكرانيا فقدت اراضيها ليست روسيا فقدت
اراضيها
فتم شبه جزيره القرم اعتمادا على استفتاء
سنه 2014
خساره لاوكرانيا ف- همم فهذا واضح جدا نعم
في روسيا كانوا يتمنون ان تتطور هذه
العمليه بشكل اسرع من كان يقول انه لنهايه
السينيه روسيا ستصيطر على الشواطئ البحر
الاسود ايضا على مدينه عيسى والاخيره نعم
روسيا سيطرت فقط على شاطئ بحر ازور ولكن
هل هذا قليل
الدكتوره خليني انقل هذا سؤال 16% من
القواعد او من الاراضي الاوكرانيه ليس
بالقليل دكتور
يعني اعتبارا من بدايه الحرب بدايه الحرب
احنا نحسب من سنه 14
جزء من المنطقه الشرقيه
بصفه عامه كان اجمالي تقريبا 20% دمار
يعني اما حاليا احنا بمعنى كذلك
عن ان نستعيد يعني 50% من هذول الاراضي
كلها فاهم شلون يعني اما بالنسبه ل اذا
حسبنا الاراضي فقط اعتبارا من بدايه
المرحله الاخيره هذه المرحله الشديده من
الحرب الغزو المباشر الروسي من فبراير همم
السنه
الجاريه
فحررنا
37% من العراق
المشكله ليست 20% او 16% او حتى 5% اللي
تطرح وضايفتي هي تقول لك بانه خير دليل
على ان روسيا تتقدم بخطوات صحيحه هي
امتلاك لهذه الاراضي بهذا النظر عن القرم
قديما تقول لك بانه منذ بدايه الغزو روسيا
تمكنت من السيطره على 16% 20% المشكله مش
في النسب المشكله بان روسيا تتقدم وتحصل
على اهداف تتمكن من السيطره على هذه
الاهداف وهي تدمر هذه المناطق يعني في نفس
الوقت وتقتل الناس هناك عمليات التصفيه
مستمره هناك قبور جماعيه حاليا يعني
موجوده في كل مكان التي تحررت يعني من قبل
الجيش الاوكراني يعني هناك عبر كبير على
السكان المحليين يعني هناك تدمير المباني
وحشيه بربريه يعني همم
تريد ان تتقدم برا ولا تريد استخدام
الصواريخ حتى لا تقصف المدنيين كونها كذلك
مباني المدمر في مدينه العاصمه يعني وفي
كل مكان انا شاهد عيونا يعني انا نفسي شفت
التدمير يعني ماذا التدمير يعني وماذا
القتل يعني هذا صراحه يعني وموجود في كل
مكان كل مكان نحن همم نستمع تقارير الناس
يعني هناك همم النيابه العامه تعمل في كل
حته يعني هناك الاف من القضايا الروسي
عادي يعني وحتى للمحاكم الجواليه الدوليه
همم عن جرائم الحربيه
في روسيا تتقدم ولا يهمها حجر او بشر همم
طيبتها
يعني
نستمر
يقول بانه روسيا لا تهمها هذه تفاصيل
المهم هي الاهداف همم كلامه يؤكد على ان
هناك مشكله في تقدم الروس يعني حتى معركه
خيرسون التي سميت كن ذكرت منذ البدايه
سميت بام المعارك اذا لم تتمكن روسيا من
التقدم كما خططت لذلك فهناك مشكله كبيره
انا اعرف تماما بان رئيس بوتينكا قائد همم
القائد الاعلى للقوات الروسيه كان يحلم
بسيطره على شواطئ البحر الاسود وما زال
ولكن بالفعل لا ارسل لم تحقر ذلك ولكنها
حققت بعد الشيء كل الاوكرانيين خسروا هل
لديهم وهم ان روسيا ممكن ان تنهزم في هذه
المواجهه اذا كان لديهم مثل هذا وهم وهذا
خطير لانه روسيا ممكن ان ترد وسترد همم
خطه له يوم المضاد والى اخره انا ما زلت
مقتنعه انه روسيا لديها قدرات على هذا
الشيء السؤال فيه وجود الاراده السياسيه
وفي وضع النقد السياسيه
نتحدث عن من يمتلكها ولكن من يفق من يفتقد
ومن يعيق فعلا طرح حلول سياسيه ومفاوضات
حقيقيه
قد رايناها خلال هذه العمليه وانتم ذكرتم
مثلا همم موضوع تعبئه كانت هناك اخطاء
ويتم الان تصحيحها فااا الفساد
لا اتحدث عن الاخطاء حدثتني حظرتك عن
امكانيه ان يكون هناك حل سياسي وان تكون
هناك مفاوضات همم هل هي متاحه في هذه
المرحله من التصعيد
نعم انا اعتقد انه نحن مازلنا في تقاطع
طرق
وامام روسيا عدد خيارات منها التحضر
للهجوم المضاد هذا الخيار مازال موجود
وعلى اوكرانيين ان يكون حزيرين وان لا
يراهن على
انتصار عسكري هذا خطا كبير وهذا ممكن يؤدي
الى ضحايا اكثر هذه
فشل روسيا
واو يعني في قوه النظام الروسي بصراحه
اصبح رهو عن يعني همم هاشم شو يعني بعد
هذه المعركه بصراحه حتى في داخل الروسي
ولكن النقاش هناك همم شديده يعني هناك
انتقادات شديده يعني بالنسبه للحكومه
وكذلك بدرجه الروسيه
المتدربه شديده يعني هناك تقريبا حسب
التقارير حتى تقارير الغربيه على سبيل
المثال هناك اقل شيء 100 100,000 جندي
يعني
همم استشهدوا او جرحوا يعني الى طريقه لا
تسمح لهم بالعوده الى ساحه القطار يعني
مدينه تقريبا كامله من الجنود الروس وليس
الجنود بساطعه انماط جنوط متدربين يعني من
جنود من قوات النخبه يعني اما هذول يعني
من التعبئه حتى ولو تصححت بعد الاخطاء
هؤلاء الناس يعني
امس كانوا فلاحين وكانوا سواقين التكاسي
عامل ايه انا من المصانع واليوم هم في
القتال واعماره من يزيد على 50 سنه 60 سنه
احيانا يعني او هم يعني هكذا يعني ما في
قوه بشريه مفقوده تقريبا يعني بالنسبه
للقوه للجميع اهم عنصر اما بالنسبه للجانب
الفني همم
تراث من الحرب العالميه الثانيه تقريبا من
الدبابات يعني وحتى همم
بعض المدافع يعني من قبل الحرب العالميه
الثانيه يعني استعملونك صحه الغذاء احيانا
حتى الى شراء الى شراء الذخيرها من كوريا
وكذلك الصواريخ من ايران
انا اخشى انه اوكرانيين ما زالوا عايشين
في هذه الاوهام ما هم يعتقدون انه هذا
الانسان
يعني انه اوكرانيا ممكن ان تتقدم
وهذا خطا كبير وهذا ممكن ان يؤدي الى
اطاله هذه الازمه هناك سيناريو اخر وهو
سيناريو تجميد هذه المواجهه عند خط التماس
ولكن لازم تكون هناك اراد سياسيه من قبل
طرفين نحن نشعر في موسكو انه حتى دوليين
وحتى امريكان اصبح ان يجز نبض هذه
الامكانيه لا هي درجه القياده الاوكرانيه
مستعده لتجميد هذه المواجهه براي من
المستحيل الايجاد حل سياسي
شكرا جزيلا على حضوركم والم صح في شؤون
السياسيه ولا استراتيجيه الروسيه الينا
سبونينا ومكيافا الدكتور اليكساندر
بكومولوف مدير المعهد الوطني الاوكراني
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا لكم للنقاش في
بقيه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]